[Musique]
bonjour Jean-Noël barreau bonjour c'est
la dernière sensation du monde numérique
les progrès de l'intelligence
artificielle à tel point que l'ONU s'en
est à l'armée ce week-end la dignité
humaine et les droits humains sont
gravement menacés par ces progrès écrit
l'Organisation des Nations Unies est-ce
que vous partagez ce constat chat GPT
puisque c'est ce dont vous parliez c'est
un outil fascinant mais à ce stade ça
n'est qu'un qu'un perroquet approximatif
qui restitue parfois un peu
maladroitement les sommes astronomiques
d'informations qu'il a compilé sur
Internet demandez-lui qui a gagné la
dernière Coupe du monde de football et
vous ne serez pas déçu parce qu'il vous
répondra la France alors c'est une
consolation pour nous et ça dépend
dernier ça n'est tout simplement pas la
vérité mais le mérite de chat GPT c'est
effectivement de mettre en lumière la
place grandissante qu'occupe
l'intelligence artificielle dans nos
vies quotidiennes avec ses promesses et
ses risques ces promesses d'abord il
faut bien le dire pour l'accélération du
progrès scientifique et médical parce
que grâce à sa capacité à analyser des
sommes très importantes d'information
l'intelligence artificielle sauve des
vies sans l'intelligence artificielle
nous n'aurions pas pu découvrir le
vaccin contre le covid aussi rapidement
et nous pouvons grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle détecter beaucoup plus
précocement les cancers et donc les
soigner vous voyez donc l'impact positif
ça peut avoir dans nos vies mais
évidemment il y a des risques des
risques de discrimination de
manipulation de déshumanisation des
questions éthiques et démocratiques
il y a des risques associés à
l'intelligence artificielle qui qui
restitue comme je disais des
informations que la collectées sur
internet mais qui n'a pas de faculté de
jugement ni d'appréciation et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il nous faut agir
et donc vous dites comme comme l'ONU oui
il y a une menace il y a la partie
opportunité mais faut qu'on fasse aussi
attention à cette partie sur les droits
humains sur la dignité humaine parce que
comme vous dites à la discrimination ce
que nous voulons faire c'est deux choses
la première c'est que nous voulons
maîtriser cette technologie une vie
plutôt que de les subir parce que nous
ne devons pas passer à côté de cette
vague d'innovation et c'est pourquoi
ce robot conversationnel pour ceux qui
auraient pas suivi sur Internet ou
effectivement on pose des questions et
des réponses et qui parfois vous le
disiez tombe à côté absolument nous
voulons maîtriser cette technologie
plutôt que de la subir et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous investissons
massivement avec le plan France 2030
annoncé par le président de la
République il y a un an et demi pour
former de plus en plus d'experts en
intelligence artificielle en France pour
soutenir des projets liés à ces
nouvelles technologies pour en avoir la
maîtrise et puis la deuxième chose c'est
que nous devons poser un certain nombre
de bornes et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la France a porté au niveau
européen un règlement qui fixe la
responsabilité des concepteurs de
système d'intelligence artificielle
prenez par exemple un concepteur de
système qui a vocation à aider les
ressources humaines à faire un premier
tri des CV ou un système d'intelligence
artificielle qui va aider le banquier à
décider à qui il octroie
crédit et bien c'est concepteurs devront
préalablement tester leur système en
faire état aux autorités et signaler
tout incident lié par exemple à la
discrimination c'est-à-dire un choix
abusif de en direction des hommes ou des
femmes ou de ou sur tel autre critères
et ça c'est un réglement qui rentre en
application quand qui est prêt qui c'est
un règlement qui a peur franchi la
première étape des discussions
européennes l'étape du conseil qui est
désormais entre les mains du Parlement
et nous espérons qu'il puisse être
adopté cette année pour entrer en
vigueur dans les mois qui suivront c'est
pas trop tard dans les mois qui suivront
ça va très vite on voit qu'il y a avant
ça à pas de géant ce qui est important
en tout cas et c'est l'esprit dans
lequel nous avons porté ce règlement
c'est à la fois de fixer un certain
nombre de bornes mais aussi de faire en
sorte que l'Europe soit un terrain dans
lequel on peut innover en intelligence
artificielle pour éviter que dans 10 ans
nous soyons dépendants d'intelligence
artificielle je suis aux États-Unis ou
en Chine justement parce que vous parlez
d'innovation comment faire pour ne pas
non plus brider l'innovation puisque
cette question de la protection des
données elle peut avoir un
un impact négatif sur le développement
justement des des nouvelles
intelligences artificielles il faut des
données pour qu'elles soient efficaces
alors sans rentrer trop dans le dans le
jargon réglementaire ce que nous avons
proposé au niveau européen c'est que en
même temps que nous fixons des
responsabilités des règles des interdits
et des obligations nous ouvrons ce qu'on
appelle des bac à sable réglementaires
c'est-à-dire des espaces dans lequel les
jeunes entreprises peuvent innover
tester des nouveaux systèmes sous l'oeil
attentif mais bienveillant du régulateur
pour ne pas étouffer justement la
capacité de l'Europe à innover donc pour
bien comprendre l'idée c'est de fixer
des règles qui s'appliqueraient
notamment aux géants aujourd'hui
américain ou chinois vous me dites le
règlement européen il s'appliquera on
est d'accord à tout intelligence
artificielle utilisé sur le sol européen
absolument qu'elle soit étrangère
absolument et de laisser pour les
entreprises de taille plus modeste des
libertés d'innovation absolument et ces
libertés d'innovation vous parliez de
bac à sable ça veut dire que c'est fait
derrière le rideau avant qu'elle
devienne public ou alors est-ce que
elles pourront précisément c'est un
terrain d'expérimentation avant que les
solutions puissent être généralisées
est-ce que ça a du sens aujourd'hui
Jean-Noël Barraud quand on voit une
grande école par exemple comme Sciences
Po interdire l'utilisation de ce robot
conversationnel de de chat GBT est-ce
que ça va dans le sens de l'histoire je
dis tout à l'heure il ne faut pas que
nous passions à côté de cette nouvelle
vague il faut replacer l'intelligence
artificielle à sa place l'intelligence
artificielle ne remplacera pas
l'intelligence humaine elle l'assistera
et donc l'urgence c'est évidemment de
former les générations à venir mais en
vérité les générations actuelles assez
nouveaux outils et les annonces du
ministre de l'éducation nationale il y a
deux semaines sur le l'introduction du
code au collège vont dans ce sens le
sens d'une appropriation des Français le
code de la route c'est apprendre à coder
donc apprendre à coder ou en tout cas
apprendre comment fonctionne ces
intelligences artificielles qui n'ont
rien de magique je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure en qualifiant chaque GPT de
perroquet il s'agit simplement de de
technologie qui permettent de
synthétiser des sommes astronomiques
d'information ce qui nous permet de
gagner du temps il ne faut pas avoir ça
comme une menace avec les réserves que
j'ai évoquées mais il faut voir ça comme
la capacité à nous assister dans un
certain nombre de tâches complexes par
exemple qui a interdit chat GPT à ses
étudiants est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qu'il fallait faire qui
est nécessaire parce qu'il faut le temps
justement de l'appréhender je crois
qu'il va falloir faire rentrer
progressivement ces outils dans nos
méthodes d'apprentissage ajuster très
certainement certaines modalités
d'examen pour éviter que la triche ne
soit ne soit trop facile et je crois que
l'important c'est vraiment que nous nous
approprions ces outils que nous en
tirions le meilleur profit il y a pas de
filtre pour déceler l'utilisation pas de
chat GPT il en existe je pense que
openéa est la société qui a publié chat
GPT aurait mieux fait d'attendre d'avoir
ses filtres avant de publier le logiciel
elle vient dans publier un ils ne sont
pas tout à fait parfaits mais vous savez
l'enseignement supérieur c'est toujours
à ajuster pour essayer d'identifier
entreprise ou pour faire en sorte qu'il
ne puisse pas y en avoir et j'ai toute
confiance que nous y parviendrons et
vous encouragez donc les professeurs les
enseignants à se saisir de ce type de
filtre bien sûr avec toutes les réserves
de de ce type de fit mais aussi de ce
type d'outils en ayant bien conscience
il faut pas l'interdit il faut pas
empêcher son utilisation dans nos lycées
dans nos universités je crois qu'il faut
l'utiliser comme un démonstrateur de ce
que peut faire l'IA et de l'intelligence
artificielle et de ce qu'elle ne peut
pas faire tout simplement Macron reçoit
ce soir les acteurs de la de la French
tech c'est quoi la french tech
la french tech c'est la communauté des
jeunes entreprises de croissance et
d'innovation en France il y a quelques
années le président de la République a
voulu créer un classement le French tech
120 et le Next 40 qui met en valeur les
jeunes entreprises d'innovation les plus
prometteuses dans notre pays et ce soir
nous en révélons la liste le constat
c'est que ce classement juste c'est le
classement des jeunes entreprises
d'innovation les plus prometteuses les
celles qui connaissent la plus forte
croissance et le constat que nous
faisons c'est que depuis quelques années
ces entreprises se sont considérablement
développées et que sous le quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron la France est devenue
l'écosystème d'innovation en Europe le
plus attractif et le plus dynamique
de la French tech justement c'est
doctolib c'est blablacar c'est Lydia par
exemple absolument ce sont ces
fournisseurs de d'applications que nous
utilisons désormais au quotidien trois
Français sur 5 utilisent les solutions
développées par la french tech ce succès
c'est vu que c'est français et c'est un
succès pour tous les Français c'est un
succès français parce que grâce à ces
entreprises la France renoue avec sa
nature profonde de grande nation
d'innovation et d'entrepreneuriat mais
c'est un succès pour tous les Français
parce que ces entreprises ont créé en
quelques années des dizaines des
centaines de milliers d'emplois dans
tous les territoires de France des
territoires qu'elle contribuent parfois
à revitaliser à régénérer à
réindustrialiser et est-ce que la France
est encore dans la course du coup ce que
je comprends c'est que vous dites
qu'elle n'est pas simplement dans la
course sur l'innovation numérique c'est
qu'elle est presque aux avant-postes en
Europe elle a pris le leadership et ces
entreprises c'est du concret on le
disait 500 000 emplois pour les startups
en France trois Français sur cinq qui
utilisent ces applications et des
solutions qui sont conçues pour relever
les grands défis est-ce qu'elle soit
aussi en quelque sorte de victimes de la
crise on sait que un certain nombre
d'entreprises évoquent en ce moment un
tarissement des financements c'est
encore plus vrai pour les start-up
il y a une période d'incertitude que
nous sommes en train de traverser c'est
la raison pour laquelle avec Bruno Le
Maire nous avons engagé des discussions
avec les assureurs qui investissent au
capital des entreprises pour qu'il
maintienne leurs engagements et que cela
ne la situation actuelle n'interrompt
pas la croissance de nos entreprises et
en même temps de ce que je comprends des
de ce que vous essayez de faire avec les
startups l'idée c'est plutôt de mettre
en avant celle qui lève beaucoup
d'argent mais plutôt celle qui justement
crée de l'emploi qui réindustrialise qui
investissent sur le territoire français
ce que nous voyons cette année c'est
qu'on voit de plus en plus apparaître
dans ce classement que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure des entreprises qui sont
issues de découverte scientifique dans
le laboratoire universitaire c'est plus
les millions d'euros qu'on le met avant
des entreprises qui indiquent qui ont
des des qui ont une vocation
industrielle des entreprises qui ont des
solutions pour le défi climatique et je
veux le dire ici nous ne réussirons pas
le défi climatique à relever le défi
climatique sans la mobilité des
carbonées comme blablacar sans
l'agriculture Bacab carbone comme des
entreprises comme innovafeed ou une
secte et sans la transition écologique
de toutes les entreprises c'est comme
les solutions que propose et covadis qui
est l'une des entreprises le Real ce
soit juste vous parliez de d'emploi
est-ce que ces entreprises elles sont
les reins assez solides pour résister à
l'année de turbulence là qui vient de
commencer en terme de croissance ce que
nous allons dévoiler ce soir c'est que
ces entreprises ont vu leur nombre
d'emplois croître pendant l'année 2022
l'écosystème l'innovation qui arrive
l'écosystème d'innovation en France a
mieux résister que les autres
écosystèmes européens et américains
c'est le signe d'une maturité atteinte
par ces entreprises innovation et c'est
une grande satisfaite est-ce qu'elles
sont elles aussi confrontées au manque
de main d'oeuvre bien sûr et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous voulons avec
le président de la République formé 400
000 experts du numérique en plus à
l'horizon 2030 400 000 pour faire en
sorte que la France tienne ce rang et
que ces entreprises puissent recruter
dans les meilleures conditions Jean-Noël
barreau secrétaire d'État secrétaire
chemin ministre délégué en charge du
numérique et de la télécommunication les
arnaques au SMS se multiplient depuis
quelques mois elles sont de plus en plus
allé borées et élaborés des milliers de
personnes ont reçu par exemple ces
dernières semaines ces derniers jours un
faux texto de l'assurance maladie qui
affirmait que leur carte Vitale n'était
pas à jour l'objectif étant évidemment
de les amener sur un site pour aspirer
leurs données personnelles les données
bancaires notamment est-ce que les
voleurs ont toujours une longueur
d'avance finalement sur le gendarme vous
avez raison de dire nous assistons à une
très forte progression de l'insécurité
numérique qui n'a pas reçu de faux SMS
sur le compte de formation sur Amélie
sur la sécurité sociale sur les
vignettes critères c'est tout simplement
insupportable alors face à ça est-ce
qu'il faut se méfier déjà par principe
de ces SMS là face à ça il faut adopter
un certain nombre de gestes barrières en
ligne être vigilant mais face à ça il
est aussi de la responsabilité du
gouvernement la puissance publique
d'agir c'est la raison pour laquelle il
y a 5 ans nous avons créé un site unique
de référence pour les victimes d'arnaque
au SMS et des cyber arnaques plus
généralement ce site c'est cyber
malveillance au singulier.gouv.fr et
j'invite celles et ceux qui ont été
victimes de ce type d'arnaque à se
tourner vers ce site pour y retourner en
retard finalement quand on était victime
vous avez raison et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut prévenir ces attaques
et conformément à l'engagement du
président de la République pendant la
campagne je travaille actuellement au
développement d'un filtre anti-arnac un
filtre anti-arnac qui préviendra
préventivement l'internaute ou l'usager
lorsqu'il s'apprête à se diriger vers un
site qui a été
identifié comme un site arnaque ce sera
un rempart contre ces arnaques au faux
SMS comprenez bien qu'il faut faire
cesser cette angoisse qui saisit nos
concitoyens dans l'espace numérique de
faire l'espace numérique un espace de
confiance et avec ce filtre entière NAC
voulons garantir à tous les Français la
cybersécurité du quotidien je reçois un
sms sur mon téléphone qui me dit
attention
vous devez 500 euros à l'assurance
maladie avec un lien si je clique sur le
lien malencontreusement là il y a une
fenêtre qui va me dire attention vous
arrivez dans un site frauduleux
exactement et donc je n'irai pas sur le
site et dans seulement vous aurez la
liberté vous aurez la liberté d'y aller
mais vous aurez reçu un avertissement
vous indiquant qu'il s'agit d'un site
ayant été identifié comme un site
arnaque et à partir de quand il sera mis
en place ce filtre nous travaillons à ce
que à l'horizon de la Coupe du monde de
rugby une première version soit
disponible une version expérimentale
pour qu'elle soit enrichie et que elle
puisse être généralisée à l'horizon des
Jeux Olympiques 2020 septembre 2023
pourquoi parce que vous craignez plus
d'arnaque à cause de la Coupe du monde
de rugby tout simplement parce que c'est
un sujet complexe qui qui prend du temps
et et qu'il nous faut faire sérieusement
ensuite vous avez raison de le rappeler
pendant les épis les événements
internationaux comme la Coupe du monde
de rugby comme les Jeux Olympiques on
voit typiquement les arnaques se
multiplient et qui nous faut donc être
prêt alors le filtre anti-arnac Népal la
seule réponse mais c'est une réponse
pour la cybersécurité du quotidien ouais
parce que il y a ce filtre que vous
évoquez mais il y a aussi un un
cyberscore que sur lequel vous vous
planchez de quoi s'agit-il exactement on
connaît le nutri-score mais alors le
cyberscore le cyberscore c'est une idée
parlementaire qui a bien des des
éléments comparables à au nutrition il
s'agit pour les sites Internet qui sont
les plus consultés par les Français
d'avoir un indicateur qui va du vert au
rouge et qui précise à l'internaute si
les données personnelles ou si les
données de paiement qui va déposer sur
ce site sont bien sécurisés c'est une
manière et bien de valoriser les sites
qui sécurisent les données de leurs
internautes et puis d'inciter ce qu'ils
ne le font pas et bien à se mettre à la
page où ce cyberscore ce cyberscore il
est lui aussi en cours de développement
notre objectif c'est qu'à la fin de
l'année 2023 il puisse apparaître sur
les sites Internet les plus consultés
par les directement on va sur le site de
sa banque par exemple on verra
apparaître en vert la pas de problème
vos données elles sont protégées
absolument ça vous donne le nutri-score
dans les rayons des supermarchés
examiner bientôt à l'Assemblée nationale
pour créer une majorité numérique sur
les réseaux sociaux comment ça va
fonctionner
nos enfants sont victimes en ligne
d'atteinte brutale à leur intimité et
alors développement affectif un seul
exemple 2 millions d'enfants sont
exposés chaque mois au contenu
pornographique sur internet quand on dit
enfant c'est moins de 15 ans moins de 13
ans
2 millions de d'enfants de mineurs sont
exposés au contenu pornographique c'est
un scandale qui me révolte et qui Maker
comme père de deux enfants comme citoyen
et comme responsable politique mais ça
ne s'arrête pas là parce qu'en réalité
la plupart des des sites qui sont
réservés aux adultes ou qui ont des
limites d'âge fixées par la loi ou
fixées par les conditions générales
d'utilisation de ces sites ne sont pas
respectés et bien nous ce que nous
voulons faire parce que j'allais dire
c'est de mettre fin à ça et faire enfin
respecter la loi sur Internet parce
qu'il n'est pas acceptable que subissent
sur internet des zones de non droit
surtout quand il s'agit de nos enfants
et donc comment on fait une majorité
numérique sur les réseaux la proposition
de loi qui est en cours de discussion à
l'Assemblée nationale elle veut pousser
les grands réseaux sociaux à faire
respecter les limites d'âge à
l'inscription et en particulier une
condition à l'inscription sur le réseau
social qui est le recueil du
consentement parental et donc une fois
que cette loi aura été adoptée les sites
de les éditeurs de réseaux sociaux
devronter qui devra par exemple être à
tester de l'âge de la personne qui
essaye de créer un compte puisque
aujourd'hui en théorie un enfant ne crée
pas de compte tout seul mais il peut
mentir sur son âge alors la première
chose que que nous avons fait c'est que
nous avons décidé de généraliser le
contrôle parental par défaut sur tous
les appareils vendus en France sur les
smartphones du smartphone à la console
de jeux vidéo en passant par la tablette
concrètement lorsque
à partir de l'année prochaine vous
achèterez un appareil de ce type en
France le contrôle parental sera
installé par défaut il restreindra
l'accès au site pour adultes aussi de
pornographique il fera respecter les
limites d'âge fixées pour les réseaux
sociaux c'est 13 ans très souvent pour
un certain nombre de ces réseaux sociaux
et puis il permettra aux parents de
contrôler le temps passé sur l'écran
mais on sait très bien que les
adolescents de 15 ans sont bien plus
forts que nous en informatique ils vont
très facilement détourner ce type de
de procédures c'est vrai leur un
scellénation mais ce n'est pas la une
raison pour ne pas agir vous savez
chaque jour que nous gagnions chaque
enfant que nous préservons de certains
contenus contre lesquels nous voulons
les dès qu'elle nous voulons les
protéger c'est un jour
utile et comment on fait concrètement
ensuite il adolescent veut aller sur ces
sites pornographiques et ils seront sur
le site
à ce jour c'est très facile il suffit de
dire oui j'ai 18 ans alors que c'est
faux mais personne vérifie finalement
c'est pourquoi est-ce que ça changera
c'est pourquoi il y a nous avons durci
la loi pour imposer au site porno de
vérifier sérieusement l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs et ils le font ils ne le
font pas alors même qu'il existe
aujourd'hui des solutions pour le faire
ils n'ont aucune excuse pour ne pas le
faire
c'est alors quoi il faut les condamner
vous les poursuivez en justice
aujourd'hui leur dossier est sur le
bureau du juge qui décidera
prochainement de les bloquer et de les
référencer si le juge pertinent ceci
étant dit nous continuons à travailler
parce que notre objectif c'est que ces
solutions puissent être effectives et je
l'ai dit des solutions existent
aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas 100%
anonyme notre objectif prendre en photo
une carte d'identité ou un passeport ça
existe pour d'autres sites en
l'occurrence ça existe dans d'autres
procédés ça existe et c'est une
protection de première approche mais ce
que nous voulons nous c'est une
protection intégrale des mineurs mais
sans fichage et sans piratage
dans laquelle la CNIL a à proposer un
schéma un système dit de double anonymat
qui permet de respecter ces conditions
des entreprises s'en sont saisies un
certain nombre d'entre elles m'ont
d'ailleurs contacté à ce sujet
c'est-à-dire que ce soit directement
l'identité ce ne sont pas les sites
pornos qui recueilleront directement
l'identité de tiers il y aura une forme
de tiers et ces entreprises intéressées
vont pour certaines d'entre elles
commenceraient à expérimenter ces
solutions au mois de mars donc si je
résume il existe des solutions de
vérification d'âge aujourd'hui les sites
n'ont donc aucune excuse pour ne pas
vérifier l'âge de nos enfants à l'entrée
sur les sites pornographiques c'est ces
solutions ne sont pas encore parfaites
l'acnil a posé un cadre des entreprises
sans saisissent et dans quelques mois
une solution de préservation de
l'anonymat sera prête je précise que la
CNIL c'est la Commission Nationale
Informatique et Liberté journal Barrault
les journalistes d'un consortium n'ont
fait partie Radio France ou enquêter
pendant 6 mois sur les pratiques de
société spécialisée dans la manipulation
de l'information
deux d'entre elles implantées en Israël
et piloté par d'anciens membres des
services secrets et de l'armée ont géré
des milliers de profils sur les réseaux
sociaux pour manipuler des opinions
influencer des élections pour manipuler
aussi des journalistes peu scrupuleux
qui ont détriment de leur média ont
relayé une propagande étatique est-ce
que vous aviez connaissance de ces faits
avant l'enquête révélée entre autres par
Radio France je veux saluer le travail
remarquable de de la cellule d'enquête
de Radio France qui a permis de
débusquer ces mercenaires de
l'information qui propagent des fausses
nouvelles à des fins commerciales et
politiques et je veux aussi dire que
c'est bien la liberté de la presse sont
pluralismes et son indépendance qui ont
permis ici de mettre la lumière sur une
une donc vous ignorez de désinformation
la désinformation c'est l'une des
menaces les plus lourdes qui pèsent sur
nos démocraties c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous agissons le président
de la République a voulu créer en 2021
un nouveau service de l'État consacré à
la lutte contre les la désinformation et
les ingérences étrangères il s'agit de
vigilum et vigime est déjà au travail
puisque pendant les élections
présidentielles et législatives en
France il a identifié ce service et il a
fait échec à 5 tentatives d'ingérence
étrangère par la désinformation sur les
réseaux sociaux pendant les élections
2022 Jean-Noël barreau la loi interdite
fabriquer des faux papiers d'identité
pourquoi ne pas interdire de créer des
faux profils en ligne et éviter ainsi
ce type de d'opération de l'étranger
nous avons pris une loi parce qu'il nous
semblait important de renforcer notre
arsenal juridique en 2018 la loi contre
la manipulation de l'information qui
crée une procédure juridicière express
pour ordonner le retrait des contenus ou
évent la suppression des comptes en
période électorale et qui crée un droit
de coopération pour les plateformes donc
le travail est en cours pour améliorer
la détection le partage d'informations
et la remédiation c'est à dire la
correction de ce type de situation
Jean-Noël barreau merci beaucoup
ministre délégué en charge de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications à vitesse matinée